[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
whatever
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
on my way
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you come back
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
okay
week 15 and we are here fellas it's week
15 and we're still surviving and
thriving how we feeling today on this
week 15. we're a little early but money
still to be made today
I want to check in with you because Ryan
and I are on the East Coast so you know
9 A.M we're fine you're you're on the
west coast 6 a.m in Arizona how you
doing
hey we're thriving we are thriving and
surviving out here uh in Arizona but uh
yeah you guys do it yeah you mentioned
that Greg is on the west coast Sam I
think you were the last one to to call
in here were you not
I was but uh I have a newborn so I'm I
have excuses for everything for the rest
of my life yeah
Sam did just get here
full transparency Sam did just get here
like two minutes ago so he's like fresh
fresh out the bed straight to you guys
but let me let me introduce everybody
let me formally introduce everybody my
name is Greg Avery next to me is the man
I like to call the man the myth and the
legend Sam Richmond that is our sharp
here at BR bed and next to him is the
man that connects us to you producer
Ryan we're giving out our Best Bets make
sure you guys drop your locks in the
chat because we'll be grading your picks
at the end of the show but right now we
need your help to build another
anytime touchdown parlay and Ryan I'm
not gonna lie bro I'm trying to win
today I'm trying to win today like we
need to get in the win column we need to
get in the win column we started off hot
now we're like one leg away these last
couple weeks we're like one leg away we
need to get in the win column so today
everybody we need to win we need winners
only please in the chat Ryan tell us
what we need from the people I just said
it but tell them again bro yeah sure
let's repeat ourselves it's early people
need to hear it again uh we need your
locks uh we need you to get into the
chat and let us know who's scoring a
touchdown today uh we will plug it in we
will debate it uh I will say my guide to
onions uh is reminding us that last week
he uh he wanted Boston Scott in the
parlay and Boston Scott was plus 550. I
put it in and I'm not and I Told You So
guy not I told you it's a guy whatsoever
I put it in and uh Greg and Sam told me
no not gonna not gonna pass blame I
would never pass blame but I just want
us to understand what happened last week
Ryan okay okay if that's if that's what
we're saying it was multiple times where
we had winners locked in but you wanted
to get rich so yeah but we don't go too
far into the past we're not going to
talk about what happened a month ago two
months ago we're talking about what
happened last week Greg okay all right
that's fair enough that's fair enough do
you uh do you want to get into it and
let's uh debate a little bit while uh
while our guy Sam figures his stuff out
as he just dipped on her he didn't want
to be he didn't want to be a part of
this I mean let's do it I'll hop in the
comments we need you guys to let us know
what we are rocking with Ryan is
anything anything catch your eyes
anything you know we have to sometimes
guide the people to the plays but go
ahead but something did catch Maya in
the chat and I I
this one I'm I'm gonna stick my flag
down here and I love uh the onion so I
feel like part of this is because I feel
like we owe him one another part is
because I love this dropped Justin
Fields Justin Fields is plus 125 to
score today
I like that important note too
both Daryl Mooney and Chase Claypool are
out for the Bears today his top two
weapons if the if the Bears are gonna
keep this competitive today the man's
got to use his legs I think this is I
think this is the uh look who decided to
my back hear me look who decided to join
you're the last one in and then you dip
out for the anytime TD parlay we're at a
Justin Fields what do you want from me
well I I'd like no fight when we for
this first leg the first leg is gonna be
Justin fields
that's what the people have decided well
well did the Ryan yeah Ryan Ryan as you
can see one comment that said that
you're trying to stop that out you don't
get to just leave and then come back and
accuse me of lying I still hurt
everything yes the onions dropped it and
Michael bowley came in and put in all
caps Justin fields
what are the odds there plus 125. that's
two out of 100. I get no say on the
first leg because of my performance so
far this morning so you and Greg and the
chat can decide very Noble of you
incredibly knowing thank you thank you
Greg what do you think
I like it I like it I like it I just
don't know if I love it but it's up to
the people let's put it in thumbs up
thumbs down yeah yeah that's exactly
what we're about to do we're going to
put it in hey you guys if you guys like
Justin field give us a thumbs up if you
guys don't like justinville give us a
thumbs down uh that's Riley thumbs up
that's Riley giving this thumbs up
already yeah okay Sports bet King said
he'd rather take Justin hurts over or
Jalen hurts over Justin fields for any
time touchdown my answer
no
I don't like it minus 130 I don't like
it
I think both score I just like B
Thompson says I can rock with fields
yeah they're they're filing in they're
piling and they are piling in but as
they're pollen in there's other locks
right there in front of us I'm just
saying I know do you see
it's like 50 50.
it's like 50. the chat is never going to
be unanimous on something unfortunately
I yeah it does seem more positive than
not though
Ryan Ryan what about this bro what about
it does seem more positive it is a
little mixture I do see a lot of thumbs
down do see some thumbs up I don't know
I don't know I
I can't make a call here but Ryan I I
did see this I've seen this multiple
times a lot of people were saying
Devonte Adams
ah
yeah I I can I can get behind Devonte
Adams as a as a second leg
as a second leg we didn't even lock in
the firstly all right but yeah
can we can we just can we can we say yes
or no right now I don't I don't want to
start talking about another leg and then
we're we're swapping back and forth
Brian just said no you're right he's a
no-brainer so uh that's not me that's
not me
it says I have been talking with my
hands for the past 11 minutes on this
show
all right let's rock with it Ryan all
right let's walk with it right because
because if this don't hit it's on me
it's just gonna blame you yeah it's on
me I will take it if it doesn't hit I
will say to Onions by the way who
dropped this lock is an Eagles fan he's
giving us a bear's lock
does that does that hold no I think it's
more of like a representation of like
how not scared Eagles fans are for the
Bears today than anything yeah yeah
that's probably Fair yes yeah uh I saw
somebody drop Travis etn before as well
do you want all right we want to talk
whoa whoa whoa whoa we gotta talk 17. we
gotta talk Devonte Adams I'm sorry Ryan
yeah I just look at in the comments in
the comments well I was just about to
say number 17 I agree with Greg they're
in the comments talking about Devonte
Adams so we gotta just give the people
what they want K Lewis 61 Devonta Adams
yes let's just ask him let's go see what
he is let's ask him thumbs up thumbs
down they're taking on
Patriots oh I don't know if I like that
wait Ryan is our River your dad yes it
is yes shout out to shout out to Mr
Rivera Legend love that and he agrees
with me and he agrees with me I love
that he's nice
Devante taking on a Bill Belichick
defense I don't know
uh yeah I know it's a time it's a tough
one you guys talk you guys got it is a
tough one I don't know I
now that I know that they're playing the
Patriots
yeah it's hold on so I want to win says
Tony Pollard or miles Sanders we're not
going to take another one from the
Eagles Bears game even though I think
there's gonna be a ton of points in that
game uh s Adams says Travis etn
a uh a bunch of numbers that starts with
773 I mean what is that username let's
get it together guys uh Tony P from
Dallas
um s Riley I wish Adams was plus money
me too brother
and then that boy Brandon Belichick's
got a double Adams all game dot dot no
all right so let's get
I if we want to go to this Cowboys
Jaguars game because we had a Tony
Pollard and we had a Travis etn lock I
I also think there's gonna be a lot of
points in this game I don't think you
can go wrong the Cowboys run defense is
certified uh garbage
Travis is Sienna plus money seems
yes calm down I'm down for the sake of
time I'm down
go ahead
this doesn't feel right this doesn't
feel right you guys are not even putting
up a fight it's like you're you're
letting me cook
Brian go ahead this is also the CH no
this is the chat this is the chat
if you have an an opposite take of this
feel free throw a nice little minus 200.
of course here we go let's get this
against that Chargers poverty Rush
defense the last time the last time
the last time you did this
the last time you did do this
the Chargers that's the comment I don't
hate the
good value 75. that's good yeah I
actually don't hate that
should we add another leg no no no no
oh now Ryan's getting scared all right I
just I think we should keep it to three
it's hard enough to hit we haven't hit
this in weeks foreign
parlay so don't let the haters get us
down uh D Roberson says Kelsey two TDS
We're Not Gonna Take Kay Robinson also
then jumped in said Kelsey 2T we're not
taking two TDS but if we're gonna take
him one yeah we just we just need one if
we're gonna if we're gonna decide
between a chalky leg we have Derrick
Henry at minus 215 and then let's go to
this Chiefs Texans game
minus 195. what are you guys more con
obviously Kelsey's better odds but let's
see hey relax okay
there we go get Fields out there Dawson
Kelsey and Henry let's cash this yeah
let's go
Sam I love that idea I absolutely love
that idea let's see let's see what that
pays out
I thought we agreed you had no say in
the first place that's true that's true
but if Greg were to say that
354. guys what do we do it's Juicy
Lucy it's juicy
now run your play right Ryan right now
yeah you got it right you got your plate
put fields in there all right but which
one are we taking out are we doing
Kelsey are we doing Derrick Henry
so we let's ask the audience yeah all
right let us know Travis Kelsey or
Derrick Henry just write their name and
that's who we're gonna take out the more
names we see that's who we're going to
take out so Ryan the first two legs of
our parlay we got Justin Fields okay
Justin fields
yeah and then we got uh Travis etn to
score yep and now we're just we just
need you guys to comment Travis Kelsey
if you do not want him on the parlay
Derrick Henry if you do not want him on
the parlay Ryan I'm excited because if
we don't win
can I just say this like the risk of
going with a quarterback anytime TD is
so high
it's so much risk and I feel so much
safer in the warm arms of Travis Kelsey
and Derek Henry and Travis CTN I I just
want to say that
or Tony Pollard but rather than who
Fields the quarterback is so risky man
do you guys understand uh Sam you
decided to take a coffee break while I
was explaining why I like Justin Fields
but Chase Claypool and Daryl Mooney both
out today
how are the Bears going to score points
I disagree with that
yeah
they're saying right no I see a lot of
Chelsea's yeah remove Kelsey yeah that's
that was the last take off fields
just just saying
that's Riley says but feels isn't like a
regular QB perfect which I agree yeah he
does run the ball a lot he runs all
right we're locking it in we're locking
it in we gotta move all right
so let's let's get the parlay in a good
spot and let's tell the people what
we're rocking with okay I I would like
to say before I read this off the
perfect world for me if we lose is that
Derek Henry doesn't score because then
it's not it's not my fault
um but well the chat was Henry I was
just giving them what they wanted right
yeah yeah you didn't yeah you didn't
offer that uh Travis Kelsey plus 105
against the Dallas Cowboys uh Derrick
Henry minus 215. slip of the tongue
right you said Travis Kelsey are you
regretting your decision
I didn't even realize that
no I'm not regretting my decision Travis
etn plus 105 against the Dallas Cowboys
Derek Henry minus 215 against the LA
Chargers and Justin Fields plus 125
against the Philadelphia Eagles
three leg parlay that adds up to plus
575. this is the week this is the week
it's been too long we're due
no we are do we're a big dude make sure
you guys tell us on DraftKings and it
wouldn't be a Sunday if I didn't do a
little anytime touchdown boost magic so
we're also gonna boost my boy miles
Sanders he's on my fantasy team anytime
touchdown from minus 130 to plus 110
don't you guys go anywhere yet because
one of the most important parts of our
show is about to happen my man Sam the
man the myth the legend winning record
on the Year we're in week 15 and my man
is way above 500 he's going to give us
his six Best Bets can we get 45 seconds
on the clock Ryan we're going to sing
you to the chat go talk to the people
you know and we'll get you back in here
soon uh 45 seconds on the clock please
for my man Sam Richmond Sam are you
ready I'm ready man let's do it
45 seconds up there let's get to it all
right first pick we are going Jets money
line
um look I get it's scary bet on Zach
Wilson poverty quarterback no doubt
about it but this Jets defense is one of
the best in the league and I know
everyone's really high in the Lions
right now I really like this Lions team
but they are completely different team
offensively on the road Jared Goff has
thrown 22 touchdowns this season only
two of those is came have came on the
road let me say it again 22 touchdowns
he has only two touch ends on the road
their offense averages two full
touchdowns left on the road and not only
are they on the road away from the Dome
again they're playing just this amazing
Jets defense so I really like New York's
defense to to shut down God and lead
them to a win here
there it is my man Sam is rocking with
Zach Wilson wow Zach Wilson in the New
York Jets uh money line that's one Sam
you got five more to go we have 45
seconds back on the clock please
pick
next pick we were taking Steelers plus
three
um to me this is just a pretty big line
overreaction I think the look headline
with Steelers minus three and it's
flipped six points because the Panthers
beat a poverty Seahawks team to me that
is just an overreaction
um and I'm sure some of that line
movement has to do with the quarterback
change from Pickett to trubisky but to
me that's really not that crazy of a
downgrade yeah like in three years
Pickett is going to probably be very
good and a lot better than trubisky ever
was but as of now like I don't think
that's that big of a difference so
Steelers still have a very good defense
they're good at stopping the run which
really matters against this new Panthers
attack which is all based on the run so
I think it's gonna be a close game give
me a field goal give me the overreaction
on the Panthers I like Pittsburgh today
there it is Sam's rocking with the
Steelers rocking with the Steelers today
uh that's two Sam
two
we got four more to go 45 seconds on the
clock
there it is take it away Sam all right
next pick will probably be controversial
with producer Ryan so I'm glad that he
is away in the chat but I am going to
take the Jags plus four uh I like this
Cowboys team a lot but I'll be honest I
I was pretty concerned watching them
last week
um pretty much almost losing to the
Texans at home and what wasn't even that
flukey of a game the Texans average five
yards of play they're a yard away from
winning the game like that was a pretty
beautiful performance so I'll gladly
take the four points at home with
Jacksonville Trevor Lawrence has really
kind of taken that next step in his
career just been on absolute fire for
the last five weeks they've really been
humming so I will I will take the Jags
here with the points in a spot where
they're still contending for the
division they could still make a run
they have a lot of motivation I think
they cover
Sam three picks in it's controversial
pick right here with producer Ryan so
let's bring him in let's bring producer
Ryan in here to talk about this and also
talk about what the chat is talking
about there he is producer Ryan how we
feeling about Sam's last play and what
the chat is saying uh it's been a while
since I called you Sam fraudman I guess
I'm gonna have to bring that back
um tough because I'm on the Lions today
so that's you know real tough that we're
on opposite sides there uh ssj Perkins
had a take on that said uh Lions
punished the Giants on the road it
MetLife where they play today I told ssj
Perkins what you were going to say in
response to that so let's see if I was
right go ahead the Giants are Stinky Poo
yep yep yeah yep that's I like the
difference in all seriousness though the
difference between the Jets defense and
the Giants defense is massive like I get
it they had a good game but they have
not been the same offense on the road
yeah
um we had to take
about well Jacob said I like the Jets to
win but Detroit will cover that's
interesting because I think they're that
is interesting plus one
um it's in yeah tough take but uh Rel
said uh Cowboy is about to thrash the
Jags uh I will read Cowboys propaganda
all day long so if you guys want to drop
that go ahead
um
let's see
ssj Perkins again saying I'm rolling
with the Lions Dan Campbell gonna have
them ready uh
how about cup of joe asks if Mike White
is playing the answer is no
Zach Wilson is playing uh today tonight
I don't know what time that game starts
out there in New York today tonight
uh let's send Ryan back to the chat Sam
that's three picks got three more to go
45 seconds on the clock please there it
is Sam take it away
all right next pick we are taking Titans
plus three I'm always scary or like
worried about betting on a game
involving the Titans but I actually got
a win on them last week even though I
was betting against them but to me it's
just a really good spot to buy low on
them this is the classic I feel like
this always happens with the Titans we
always bury this team and every time we
do they always come back and brabel does
a good job of getting them back on the
right track I think this sets up really
nice from a match-up perspective the
Chargers have one of the worst Rush
defenses in the NFL
um and the Titans have a man named Derek
Henry who he's picked in our anytime
touchdown parlay and is an absolute
Beast so time's gonna keep this game on
the ground keep it out of uh Tana Hill's
hands attack dot Chargers poverty Rush
defense and you get a field goal against
a team that is really really desperate
to sort of right the ship so I like
Titans here I like this one Sam I like
this pickle see if uh Ryan Tannehill in
that offense can get clicking against
the charges but I like this one I like
this one uh you know what I haven't
heard you say today
hopefully it's coming we got four picks
four picks down two more to go
Sam 45 seconds is on the clock can we
get that up there it is take it away all
right so this one is definitely going to
be super controversial maybe more
controversial than my Broncos plus nine
last week
um but we are taking the bucks plus
three and a half against the uh
Cincinnati Bengals to me this is just
your ultimate Buy Low sell High spot in
the NFL that I think is generally pretty
profitable the Bengals are the darling
of the league right now everything like
that the Bucks everyone's down then they
looked awful the past few weeks but you
can't get too lost in those
overreactions to what you saw the week
before the the Bucks aren't great but
they're still a decent team they're 13th
overall on dvoa so they've been in
average to above average team so if
you're giving me 3.5 points at home with
Tom Brady and a really big desperation
spot I'm gonna take it every time
rocking with Tom Brady and the boys
today
they didn't look good last week but
Sam's looking for them to bounce back
this week uh that's five five pick Sam
one more to go 45 seconds on the clock
please
there it is Sam
all right last pick we are taking
Raiders moneyline really like this spot
for them at home obviously they are
coming off again just a brutal loss in
which they blew a game they should have
won against the Rams they've got some
extra time to rest I I really like them
to bounce back there and I I like this
Patriots team but I was actually pretty
concerned about what they did against
the Cardinals where I'm not even sure
they win that game if Hopkins doesn't
give them the fumble six so they really
let the Cardinals and Colt McCoy hang in
there a lot longer than they should it
was a pretty even game so
um I'm not sure this is you know that
was the big win that everyone is you
know projecting it to be so I like the
Raiders to bounce back here I like
Devonta Adams score touchdown for
Anytime CD parlay
there it is Raiders bounce back Devonte
to score a touchdown I don't know if we
added Devonte Sam I don't know if we
added Devonte well he's going to score
we should have we we got scared of
Belichick I'm just gonna blame producer
Ryan
that's yeah that's usually what we
should do actually let's bring producer
Ryan in here speaking of him producer
Ryan talk to us we're you know we're
just saying yeah boy can I chime in real
quick
I just am looking at the chat right now
the first comment I see is bro you was
trash last week I went five and one last
week on the show what do you want from
me do I need to go 6-0 or am I trash yes
okay okay five and one not good enough
yeah so here's the deal here's the deal
I would normally defend you but if I'm
gonna get disrespected while I'm not
while I'm not on screen here then I'm
with the chat you need to be six and
over your front so that's what's gonna
happen here uh darian85 jumped in uh
before trashing you for taking bucks
three and a half said he likes your Jags
pick Dak has a horrible record versus
AFC South uh Dr 87 who's not usually
positive in this chat but I will give
him credit bucks three and a half is a
lock is what he said uh j23 cash bucks
bounce back plus three and a half this
is not the love I expected for the buck
spec I'll be honest with you uh Austin
rygone says Bengals been too hot gotta
come back down to earth
okay yeah and mhb for Joe burrow last 20
starts is the most profitable QB against
the spread he's like 17 and three yeah
no they've been they've been cash cows
yeah
and you feel comfortable
uh I do well someone just you know j23
crash said dude been on fire so that
that made me feel good so I get when
somebody so you're looking you're
looking for the positive comments right
of course of course I need something
celiot uh through uh throwing a
throwback at us saying Bing Bong parlay
today all New York teams win oh
yeah I don't know I I know we didn't
touch on that game but I I couldn't play
the commanders because it was four and a
half five was just too high for me but I
I do like Washington to win tonight I
just think that's a field goal game
yeah
right there that's when we move on that
is exactly when we move on we heard from
Sam now
I got a pick for you guys and I heard my
man producer Ryan got a pick for you
guys Ryan we were talking about it
before the game talking about I mean not
the game but before the show we were
talking about it uh can you scroll down
to the Kansas City Chiefs Texas game
actually you're right there it's right
here all right look at it let's look at
this you see Patrick Mahomes to throw
over 300 passing yards and Travis Kelsey
to score a touchdown sitting that plus
200 and I absolutely love it we know
what Mahomes do in the air we know what
he does he slings that rocket and he's
been slinging it all year I can
definitely see him going to go get 300
yards against the Texans we're talking
about the Texans here guys like
literally the Houston Texans we're
talking about them and Travis Kelsey
Travis Kelsey Ryan he hasn't scored
in the last two weeks
they usually say all good things come to
an end but today we're going to say tell
them what we're going to say today Ryan
we're going to say all good things start
again
all good things start again a man Travis
Kelsey is getting into the end zone him
in my homes they're going to try to get
on one Accord especially before the
playoffs
so I like this one sitting that plus 200
put my homes to throw for 300 and Kelsey
to get a tub
I'm rocking with it I I am rocking with
it Ryan I know I know you gotta pick I
know you gotta pick talk to us about
what you like yeah so
I would have loved to take the Cowboys
-4 here and just fade Sam and that would
have been fun for me but I don't have
that much faith I will say this the Jags
have lost 20 straight games against an
NFC opponent uh Dak Prescott is 11-1 uh
as a road favorite of more uh four or
more points but I'm not taking the
Cowboys I think there's gonna be a lot
of points here I'm gonna take the
Cowboys team total over 26 and a half
mmm
the Jaguars give up a lot of points I
think this game goes back and forth I
think the Cowboys are going to try and
get off to a hot start they have been a
horrendous first half team I think the
way that you do that is feed Tony
Pollard feed Zeke Dak has been
above average I will say I know a lot of
people love Dak I'm not a big DAC guy
but they score points they put points on
the board they've been a top five
offense since he's returned uh the Jags
defense doesn't scare me whatsoever so
whatever happens with the spread in this
game I'm gonna leave that to the powers
that be but I think the Cowboys score
more than more than 26 and a half points
today
there it is always win 27-24 we all go
home all go home happy yes I will also
say uh my Giants plus seven and a half
last week because I'm a man of
accountability so I will own this yeah
bad beat I was gonna say you say this a
lot Sam uh right side it was a right
side loser you know correct yeah I was
seeing it well uh just didn't hit so
forward one on this show okay
they did lose by time yeah what are the
people saying are they saying are they
giving you uh
are they giving you a break in the
comments or what well daring 85 says I
don't know about that Greg she's maybe
done halfway through the third I thought
that last week about the Cowboys and the
Texans hung around so
I don't know about pound you're a yard
away from losing look at that hung
around
that's a they hung around uh j23 cash
Kelsey anytime touchdown he likes it uh
Donnie and Zach Wilson under 197 and a
half I mean that has nothing to do with
what we just said but he's fading Zach
Wilson today which I love
um Yeti soap ankle said the the Giants
play killed me last week bro killed me
too
killed me too
uh Jacob likes my pick
um and then mhb for Trevor Lawrence's
last five games ten tutties zero
interception QB rating of 111. that
seems like okay balling man he has been
on fire yeah so uh j23 cash also said
Mahomes over 300 over 300 yards and
Chiefs to win Mahomes anytime TD score
and Kelsey so this is he just likes the
Chiefs to Route the Texans
that's a lot of cheats yeah right yeah
I'll take but are we supposed to be
grading these or
yeah I mean let's keep it rolling just
keep it rolling keep keep listening off
uh
off commenters and me and Sam will
either grade them or say we like them
don't like them whatever
cool all right
um
Rio de Don Travis Kelsey and Isaiah
Pacheco anytime touchdown today
where does all the Chiefs today yeah
yeah it's bad news Well Kelsey's gonna
get in the end zone for Greg's
bet and so we can roast you about not
putting Kelsey in the anytime we parlay
so that's a lock uh Pacheco so we're
rooting against each other on this show
is what you're telling me yes yeah of
course okay yeah keep things fun yeah
uh I'll give it a b all right
oh
yeah I'll give it a c plus I really like
the Kelsey pick of course but the
Pacheco I just don't know
okay
yeah all right C plus it's passing
um eject these good degrees C's do get
degrees uh ejac says Jags haven't won an
NFC game since 2018 and if you're
wondering why I don't know the comments
are doing a bunch of that stuff you're
telling me well yeah no no record
against AFC who cares none of that
matters right you did take them against
the Giants correct
uh but anyway 20 20 L's in a row this
does fit my agenda so I will read it
every time if he drops his comment three
more times I will read it every single
time uh but he said taking Cowboys money
line which I believe is minus 205.
so go ahead give me your take what do
you think about Cowboys money line
rather than Cowboys minus four
I am not Lane minus 200 uh if it's part
of a parlay or something sure if you're
gonna take like Cowboys moneyline like
Chiefs money line and get it to like
minus 150 160 or whatever but I'm not
taking money through the money line in
the NFL it's a leg Greg what do you
think
a leg I like it as a leg I like it as a
leg but that's a single bet I'm not
I'm not touching it as a single bet as a
leg I like it it's a B minus b as a leg
okay that's that's not bad that's a
fridge uh donians Deontay Let's do let's
do two more Ryan and then we're gonna uh
we got to go win some money yes sir
Deontay Johnson anytime touchdown with
Mitch as his quarterback plus 240. hey I
don't like it hey
listen to my agenda that's my agenda
yeah like anyone else can score or the
game could be 9-3
I feel it minus it fits my agenda I feel
it I mean yeah I like it but the only
reason I would say
I don't like it is because I think I I
read an article about Deontay Johnson
wanting uh Mason Rudolph to be
quarterback over Mitchell trubisky oh so
scoop school we got the ladle we got the
ladle all right I'm going to do a b-plus
downgrade to a B plus based on that
scoop okay
I'll take it uh one more Ryan
we had a take in here trying to find
from Bandit Bandit 4200. uh he dropped
three plays two of them were Titans plus
three and jets money line which Sam you
already gave so I'm not yeah yeah I'm
not gonna hand him an Easy A Plus Eagles
Bears over 48 and a half is what he
dropped with those two other plays so
grade that one Eagles Bears over 48 and
a half what do you think
um see like I I don't have a strong take
there I know that's a cop-out answer it
is but they're I mean they're gonna blow
them out in my opinion okay I don't know
yeah right gotta blow them out but you
didn't take Eagles minus eight and a
half
so
correct because I don't like betting on
big favorites and the Eagles have
already screwed me in that spot when I
took them against the commanders and
they lost the game outright so
um
well before we go why don't everyone
give their World Cup final prediction
then we'll and then we'll bounce what an
absolute great great to pick Let's get
through the pick Sam uh it's the World
Cup finals in 20 minutes
big money's coming in on the under on
that pick
so uh I don't know if I like it I really
don't have a lien uh C plus
okay all right that was a friend Sam
France though France
I'll take Ransom or Ronaldo guy Messi
all right Ryan let's review let's review
the picks from today's show Before We
Say Goodbye
yes sir all right so our anytime
touchdown parlay is Justin Fields Travis
etn and Derrick Henry it's plus 575 on
DraftKings uh or anytime touchdown boost
is Miles Sanders boosted to Plus 110.
so that's our little anytime touchdown
segment Sam's six bets uh the New York
Jets money line
say what you want about it Pittsburgh
plus three Jags plus four another loser
another stinker Titans plus three bucks
plus three and a half and the Las Vegas
Raiders money lines
sounds like a two and four day to me uh
Greg's picks 300 plus passing yards and
Travis Kelsey uh receiving touchdown
plus 200 that's in the weekly specials
and then my pick my Dallas Cowboys team
total over 26 and a half points against
the Jacksonville Jaguars
there it is make sure you guys follow
make sure you guys tell us next week
we're on Thursday night at five eastern
before Thursday Night Football see you
guys then for Greg Ivory Sam the man the
myth the legend Richmond and producer
Ryan we
are out of here
peace
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign